you been married quite a while 22 years
yeah that's like a hundred and fifty in
Hollywood here yeah what do you think is
the key to keeping a marriage going that
long well I mean you have to have sex
you make that shot
you make that sound like you know it's
punishment but I think you know people I
meet people have been together a long
time and they stopped having sex and I'm
telling you my husband is like a fussy
PMS see little weirdo if he doesn't get
you know come on you guys you you you
right has a little lovin he's like what
do you need hon I'm all ears
wait now have to but I and this if this
gets you know I'm not dr. oz I'm not a
physician I don't think dr. oz is a
physician but anyway I'm not dr. Phil
he's my physician either my question is
how often are we talking what's the
frequency well excuse me I choked
minimum once a week once a week yeah I
mean if I'm on fire
it's twice a week but that's just so not
happening right now
and you find that he gets he's in a bad
mood if he's not kept on this he'll just
suddenly just get like no the butter mom
you know he'll just like pick a fight
overnight a seizure he's happy that's
not that's not him being angry that's
him having some sort of an episode yeah
well too much sex all the time
well I whatever you're doing is working
so I mean you have to communicate too
and you have to like not keep secrets
from each other you know but like sex is
one of the things right right and like
often I'm tired and I still try and do
it because he's a very good husband and
he deserves to be acknowledged so he
knows he knows that you're tired and he
knows that you're maybe not in the mood
I don't but then he knows that you're
making a concession yes that takes some
of the sexiness out of it if you're like
this is true all right let's get to work
here you know this is part of my
self-discipline is to not make it feel
like right super you know
condescending right because when I'm a
favor
yeah it often comes out like yeah yeah
you know I really do my best
mm-hmm to not make it seem that way okay
often I don't want a big male body all
up in my business when I'm really tired
I don't want a big male body up inside
my business
[Applause]
when I'm tired right I do like it sounds
like you've got your next self no oh my
gosh this is going really yeah no he
shouldn't watch this do you know I love
my husband he's amazing he's awesome
it's good lovin after 26 years yeah it's
all good
that's great
you